J'ai été visité une grotte ornée il n'y a pas longtemps.
La grotte dans laquelle tu peux trouver le plus de mains négatives, c'est dans le Sud-Ouest.
Ça m'a fasciné de voir qu'en fait, on ne sait pas vraiment à quoi ça servait, il y a un coin où les gens habitent.
Il y en a un autre, on ne sait pas si ça pourrait être des rituels, ça sert à quoi les grottes ornées en fait ?
En fait, la grotte, ce n'est pas un environnement qui est hyper confortable
pour une vie à long terme.
Donc, les campements majoritaires sont des campements plutôt extérieurs.
Ou alors, en abri sous roche, mais pas réellement en grotte profonde, parce qu'il y a un fort taux d'humidité.
Et très honnêtement, ce n'est pas très agréable.
Surtout qu'en plus, tu dois cohabiter généralement avec des bêtes
à l'époque des lions des cavernes, des ours,
des tigres, etc.
Donc, ce n'est pas forcément l'endroit le plus chaleureux si tu veux.
Mais effectivement, de temps en temps, ils y allaient de manière ponctuelle pour des séjours un petit peu court.
Et puis surtout, ils ont là-bas des activités rituelles assez exceptionnelles.
Par exemple, dans la grotte de Bruniquel,
dans la salle du fond,
les Néanderthaliens ont coupé les stalagtites,
et les ont disposé en cercle.
Tu as un énorme cercle d'environ 150 m de diamètre.
Dedans, tu as de plus petits cercles de stalagtites avec des foyers qui ont été aménagés.
Ça ne sert absolument à rien.
- Enfin, tu vois, si tu veux...
- On n'en trouve pas l'usage, mais peut-être qu'un jour on saura.
C'est ça, on en trouve pas un usage quotidien,
un usage technique.
Probablement que pour se donner autant de mal, ça devait sûrement servir à quelque chose dans leur tête.
Mais c'était peut-être une efficacité qu'on estime être une efficacité rituelle.
Pareil, pour les peintures.
C'est vraiment des choses qui sont très chronophages.
Y a un investissement de temps qui est vraiment énorme.
Un investissement technique aussi.
Parce que dans la grotte de Lascaux par exemple, tu as de petits emménagements dans les murs.
qui montrent que les mecs ont quand même faits des échafaudages
pour aller peindre dans les parties les plus hautes.
Oh énorme.
Donc, c'est beaucoup de temps, c'est beaucoup d'énergie, c'est des matériaux aussi
qui ne sont pas forcément locaux.
Il faut aller cherches les ocres, etc.
Donc c'est forcément quelque chose qui, pour eux, comptait
et qui avait un sens.
Après, on a forcément un petit peu de mal à
comprendre de quoi il s'agissait.
Mais en tout cas pour le groupe, c'est un investissement important.
J'admire beaucoup les archéologues parce qu'il y a quand même beaucoup de
choses qu'il faut essayer déterminer d'après des indices et tout.
Ça me paraît tellement casse-gueule ça.
Juste pour revenir sur cette histoire de stalagtiques, ça me fait marrer, parce que justement dans la grotte qu'on a visité.
Tout les stalagtites et stalagmites étaient coupées,
parce que la grotte se fait visiter depuis le XIXe siècle un truc comme ça.
Et les guides à l'époque, ils coupaient des stalagtites pour les filer aux visiteurs en guise de souvenir.
Des souvenir pour les riches, c'est marrant.
- Ah et j'imagine que c'était payant ?
- Bah oui évidemment.
Évidemment !
Du coup, il n'y a plus grand chose dans la grotte.
Mais sinon, on est un peu au pays des ocres, moi je reviens sur les ocres parce que
tu n'as pas des trucs un peu fun à me raconter sur ce matériel très particulier pour la Préhistoire ?
C'est des oxydes de fer, des terres avec des oxydes de fer dedans.
Le truc, c'est qu'en Provence, il y en a quand même pas mal.
Ça sert à plein de choses, il y a plein de peintres qui sont venus s'installer ici.
Cézanne a peint 1 milliard de fois la Sainte-Victoire au-dessus d'Aix-en-Provence.
Ce qui est marrant dans les ocres, c'est qu'en Préhistoire, ils utilisent de l'ocre rouge,
mais parfois aussi de l'ocre jaune et de manière extrêmement ponctuel, on en trouve moins en France, on a aussi de l'encre violette.
C'est bizarre toute cette palette de couleur pour finalement un même phénomène géologique, ça s'explique comment ?
Ça dépend de la composition de tes ocres, tout simplement.
Je pense que les trucs violets, il doit y avoir du manganèse ou de l'aluminium dedans ou des trucs comme ça.
Sinon, il y a aussi le fer ferrique et le fer ferreux, Fe2+ et Fe3+, ces trucs-là.
Même en chimie, tu peux faire des précipités de fer ferrique et ferreux qui n'ont pas la même couleur.
Du coup, sur le sol, ça influe vachement sur les sols.
C'est une histoire de composition chimique.
Dans le genre roche violette, il y a la bauxite qui n'est pas loin d'ici.
À mon avis, c'est parce qu'il y aurait de l'aluminium dedans.
Si c'est bien de la bauxite effectivement, c'est un minerai d'aluminium qui a été extrait en carrière depuis hyper longtemps,
et qui a été décrit pour la première fois aux Baux-de-Provence juste à côté d'ici, c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle la bauxite.
Ah c'est marrant ça.
Bonne anecdote.
N'est-ce pas.
C'est tout ce que j'ai. J'ai tout donné.
Moi j'ai trouvé ça très bien.